an immediately invoked function
expression or iffy for short is a
JavaScript function that runs as soon as
it is defined so let me give an example
and if I run there you'll see in the
console my favorite number is 3 note
that this function has no name and is
not stored in a variable the first and
closing parenthesis right here makes the
function and expression and the last two
parenthesis right here tell the
JavaScript compiler to invoke or call
this anonymous function immediately
hence the name immediately invoked
function expression so it's just a
function that runs right away we can
also create a named immediately invoked
function expression and we can pass in
arguments so I'm going to copy this here
make a new one and we're gonna name this
so here I use a default parameter that
means if you we don't pass in anything
it's going to set num to equal 3 however
if we do pass in something it will set
num to equal whatever we passed in so
here it's just going to do exactly what
we did up here and say my favorite
number is 3 so if we run that we should
see two times in the console yup it does
it twice for up here and up here but now
we can also call this and now look it
immediately invokes it and we can call
it again later and pass in a different
argument the most popular use of the
immediately invoked function expression
is to avoid declaring variables in the
global scope and to create closures many
JavaScript libraries use this technique
so that variable names don't conflict
between the library and programs that
might use the library here is a simple
example
so if we run that you can see this
function is going to be invoked
immediately and it's going to consult
that log the a but it's going to use the
a from within the function 3 and when we
console that log a again down here it
can't access anything within this
function or within this closure so it's
going to use the a that we defined up
here so you can see it's gonna be a 3
and then 2 because JavaScript has
function level scope all the variables
declared in this anonymous function are
local variables and therefore it cannot
be accessed outside the anonymous
function see my closure video for more
about that with es6 you can now
accomplish some of the same things as an
iffy in a different way let and Const
variables use block scope so as long as
they are placed in a block they will not
pollute the global namespace so let's
just change this example to use block
scope now it changes to be B and now
we're just going to make this into a
block so it's no longer an immediately
invoked function expression it's just a
block and we're going to change these
variables to let and if I run that see
the first 3 into R where we used a up
here but the second 3 & 2 here are where
we use B before es6 all variables had
global scope but now with constant let
you can have different scopes so you
don't always need immediately invoked
function expressions as much as you used
to
well thanks for watching my name is Bo
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good